ارتفاع قياسي في درجات الحراره
ومزيد من الظواهر الجويه الاستثنائيه خلال
الاعوام المقبله
تقييم القاتم حملته توقعاته علماء المناخ
بتقرير جديد صادر عن المنظمه العالميه
للارصاد الجويه
قالت المنظمه ان هناك احتمالا بنسبه
66% ان يتجاوز المتوسط العالمي السنوي
لحراره الارض بدرجه ونصف المستوى المسجله
ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه
وقالت المنظمه ان هناك احتمالا بنسبه
66% ان يتجاوز المتوسط العالمي السنوي
لحراره الارض بدرجه ونصف المستوى المسجله
ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه خلال واحده على
الاقل من السنوات الخمس المقبله قبل ثلاث
سنوات قدر علماء ان فرصه حدوث ذلك تقل
بنسبه عشرين في المئه
نقدر انه خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله سنصل
الى مستوى درجه ونصف لحراره سطح الارض لكن
بشكل مؤقت خلال الخمسه عشره او العشرين
عاما المقبله نقدر ان هذا قد يكون السمه
الدائمه للمناخ وفي الواقع لا عوده الى
الايام الخوالي لان لدينا بالفعل تركيزا
عاليا من ثاني اكسيد الكربون وغاز الميثان
في الغلاف الجوي وافضل ما يمكننا فعله هو
التخلص التدريجي من هذه الاتجاهات السلبيه
ذكر تقرير المنظمه ان ثم احتمالا ايضا
بنسبه
98% ان تكون واحده على الاقل من السنوات
الخمس المقبله الاكثر حراره على الاطلاق
واضافت تقرير ان تسخين القطب الشمالي
سيكون اعلى بثلاث مرات من المتوسط العالمي
وارجعت المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
ارتفاع درجات الحراره خلال الفتره المقبله
للتاثير المشترك لتغير المناخ الذي يتسبب
فيه البشر وما يسمى
وهي ظاهره مناخيه تحدث بشكل طبيعي في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ وتترافق عموما مع
ارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده في الجفاف في
بعض انحاء العالم وامطار غزيره
وفيضانات في مناطق اخرى ونبات المنظمه الى
انه سيكون لذلك تداعيات كبيره على الصحه
والامن الغذائي واداره المياه والبيئه
اسوا لم ياتي بعد